-Oh, you're a stud.
Welcome back to the show.
-I just was watching you
Thanksgiving at the parade.
Awesome job.
-Oh, yeah. Thank you.
Roots, yeah.
-It was super cool.
-Thank you, bud.
We had a good time.
How was your Thanksgiving?
-It was really nice.
We were making dinner
while we were watching you.
Well, it was actually lunch
this year, which was --
-Yeah.
-Yeah, it's good when it's lunch
because that means that my wife
isn't gonna go into the bedroom
and put her pajamas on
and then come out
to try to get people
out of the house, but...
-[ Laughs ]
-Because it ends early.
-It ends early,
and everyone goes home.
You go, "Thank you so much."
-But you know what?
I'll tell you what --
There's a guy --
I wrote his name down because
it's hard to remember.
His name is J. Kenji López-Alt.
Do you know who this is?
-No.
-This is the guy that saved
our Thanksgiving this year,
or let's say
changed it forever for the good.
Every year, we talk about
the turkey thing --
how we're going to do it,
wet brine, dry brine.
-Yes. Spatchcock.
-Spatchcock.
-Spatchcock, new thing.
Everyone is spatchcocking.
-This guy is a spatchcocker.
This guy
is an avid spatchcocker.
[ Laughter ]
We didn't actually -- What?
-That's on his resume.
-What's funny?
-He's an avid spatchcocker.
-We didn't actually spatchcock
this year.
But what we did was
before it goes into the oven,
you cover it in mayonnaise.
[ Audience groans, laughs ]
You love mayonnaise,
right, Jimmy?
Jimmy?
What's up? What's up?
You haven't lived
until you've taken a raw bird
and filled every single crevice
with herbed mayonnaise.
I'm not kidding.
-Oh, my God. Herbed mayonnaise?
-[ Chuckles ]
-That makes it
even grosser sounding.
Herbed mayonnaise?
Was it room temperature
herbed mayonnaise?
-Yeah, room temperature.
It was the breast tur--
It was the best turkey
that we've ever had.
-Yeah. Right.
-And the experience --
-Yeah, right,
it was the best turkey
you've ever had.
-I'm telling you.
-Give me a break.
What was this man's name again?
-J. Kenji López-Alt.
-Yeah. No thanks.
-No. And rubbing it
in the crevices, it's kind of --
-Do you tell everyone
you did that?
-Yeah. I mean,
it's kind of like --
-People try to trick me because
they know I don't like mayo.
And they go,
"Why don't you have this corn?"
-No, they told me --
-"Try, it Jimmy."
I go, "I know you rolled it
in mayonnaise.
I'm not gonna eat it.
Don't trick me into doing it."
-You're good at a lot of things.
You don't need to be
a great mayonnaise lover
on top of everything else.
You know? Don't feel bad.
-But what did it do to it?
Did it tenderize it?
Did it make it tangy?
Did you get a zip?
-I feel like it's like the Upper
West Side version of manliness.
I felt like I was --
-Really? On top of the world?
-It was like I was rubbing it
in these crevices.
It felt like I was
naked bow hunting or something.
[ Laughter ]
-In the middle of the woods
somewhere, just running?
-I don't know, but it was
absolutely delicious.
You don't taste the mayonnaise.
It's crispy.
-But then why do it
if you don't taste it?
If you don't taste it,
get it out of the house.
-All right. You can --
[ Laughter ]
You can talk to J. Kenji
López-Alt about this.
-I want to talk to him about it.
-He's a scientist,
and it has to do
with the proteins
interacting with the skin
of the bird.
-Oh, my God.
-Yeah, I'm serious.
-Just spatchcock it, man.
That's what you got to do.
[ Laughter ]
-Just spatchcock that thing.
-Just spatchcock it.
-Hey, we have a lot
to talk about.
-Okay.
-Last time you were here,
you told me
that you were about to do
"Beverly Hills Cop 4"
with Eddie Murphy.
-I did.
-You did?
-I did it, yeah.
-How was it?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So fun. So fun.
-I'm so psyched.
I love Eddie.
And I love Kevin Bacon.
-Eddie was great.
I mean, he made me laugh
so many times.
And, you know, he said to me --
It was really sweet
'cause, you know,
you're working with somebody,
and he's such a big
giant iconic star,
and, you know, for me, too,
you know?
I mean, it's like --
It's not like
I'm just, you know,
"Oh, whatever. That's cool.
It's Eddie Murphy."
I mean, it's Eddie Murphy.
You know?
-Yeah, exactly. Yeah.
-And he's like,
"Yeah, we're '80s guys."
And I think what he meant was
that our movies or big movies
kind of came out in the '80s --
at least my big movies.
He kept having him.
That was my one shot.
-[ Laughs ]
So, but it was great.
We had a good time.
-Had you met him before?
-No, I had never met him before.
But he told me
some great stories.
-Can you tell anyone
who you're playing?
-I can tell you --
I think I can say I'm playing
a Beverly Hills cop.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow. All right, that's --
-I think that's all I can say.
-No spoilers.
-But you know what I did?
I binge-watched all three
of them before to get ready.
And I get this thing where,
like, songs get into my head.
So, for months, it was --
[ Humming "Beverly Hills Cop"
theme ]
Find that key.
[ Both vocalize
"Beverly Hills Cop" theme ]
♪♪
-Oh, nice.
All right.
♪♪
[ Laughs ] Wow.
-Yeah, but now you got it
in all of our heads.
Why would you do this?
-I mean, it's --
-Is it trapped in your head?
-Well, it is now.
-Axel F.
-It's back.
-Axel F. was his name.
Yeah, that was Axel Foley.
Yeah, that was his --
-This is actually called
"Beverly Hills Cop: Axel Foley."
-Really?
-Yeah.
-Oh, my go-- So you're doing
that giant thing.
And then you do "Guardians of
the Galaxy: Holiday Special."
-I know, man.
-It's very funny.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's on Disney Plus.
[ French accent ]
-[ Laughs ]
-[ Normal ] I don't want to
give too much away
for people who haven't seen
the special yet.
But in this holiday special,
it's a call-back to the first
"Guardians of the Galaxy" movie
'cause Chris Pratt's character
is obsessed with you.
-Yes.
He thinks I'm a great hero.
[ Laughs ]
-Yeah. So, they --
I don't want to --
but they kidnap you, kind of.
-They do, yeah.
Yeah, they kidnap me.
-I saw a tweet, by the way.
A fan tweeted this,
and I thought this was very fun.
From TheAlphaVictor.
It said...
That's how excited fans are
that this happened.
And you made it happen.
I love that you did this.
-I had so much fun, you know?
When I was probably
starting out --
when I had amazing experiences,
I kind of used to feel like
I was too cool
to react to things, you know?
I would be like,
"Yeah, whatever, Meryl Streep.
Okay. Whatever, yeah, going to
the moon, okay, whatever."
You know what I mean?
But I'm at a point
in my life now
where I can just stop and go,
"Oh, my God.
This is crazy,
what I do for a living.
This is so cool."
When I walked onto the set
of "Guardians of the Galaxy"
and saw all of those aliens,
not to mention the Guardians,
and they're all in different
make-ups and wardrobe,
and there's Christmas stuff
all over the place.
I literally was like --
one of those moments like,
"Damn, this is fun."
-That's exactly
what I'm talking about.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes! It's supposed to be fun.
This is all fun.
-I am so grateful
to have this gig.
-I couldn't happen
to a cooler dude.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Kevin Bacon in "Guardians
of the Galaxy: Holiday Special."
Take a look at this.
-Oh!
-911, can I help you?
Hello?
-There's two --
I don't know what they are --
people in costumes.
Aah!
-♪ I want an alien
for Christmas ♪
♪ Bring me an alien
this year ♪
♪ I want a little green guy
about three feet high ♪
♪ With 17 eyes
who knows how to fly ♪
♪ I want an alien
for Christmas this year ♪
♪♪
-Aah! Aah! Aaaaah!
[ Groans ]
Oh!
[ Breathing heavily ]
♪♪
-Come on.
You're the best.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Only you can do
all this cool stuff.
I love it.
-It was fun.
-What I also think
is cool about it --
Also, in this, by the way,
on the soundtrack here,
you get to sing a holiday song
with the great band, Old 97's.
It is on the soundtrack,
which I have here.
But this is very exciting.
Not only are you awesome,
but you came here tonight.
You're going to perform
with Old 97's
the song from "The Guardians of
the Galaxy: Holiday Special"
called "Here it is,
Christmastime"
on the show tonight.
Kevin Bacon, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Guardians of the Galaxy:
Holiday Special," streaming now
on Disney Plus.
Kevin is performing
after the break.
Stick around!